one get that video up i'm gonna go get
some help i don't know if i have the
video pulled up but uh uh in the house
on uh in florida they voted to take away
the special governing privileges and tax
privileges from disney and the activists
were like no
give the corporations power corporations
off their taxes the colorado governors
wanted to bring disney to colorado he
was like hey we'll uh set you guys up
and basically what i'm thinking is yeah
right like if disney goes to colorado
spends 100 like billions of dollars
building disney world plus or whatever
they want to call it uh and then a new
governor gets in and it's like we're
shutting down disney special privilege
and like what does this guy think is
going to happen anyway he wants to bring
him out there and give him access to
build nuclear power plants again
i'm not seeing it so this is the this is
the the video we have here from twitter
it's about uh in the the house the
florida house
was voting to strip disney of their
special privileges which would be like
their special governance abilities their
ability to police or build nuclear power
plants and special tax privileges and we
ended up with this protest let me make
sure we have the the audio
appropriately configured
[Applause]
all right you can't really hear them but
they're apparently chanting this is good
trouble this is necessary trouble um
is from the a reporter from the orlando
sentinel so you actually have the left
they are in the chambers
protesting that a one of the largest
corporations in the world is losing a
tax cut good they're allowed to do it i
support the right to do it i don't agree
with your message though no i think that
they're cultists for the corporation and
they probably mickey mouse plushed
animals in their
couch and stuff we all recognize their
right to protest we are pointing out the
psychosis that is occurring when the
left is like corporations should have
tax cuts people are obsessed with it
some people are it's a mutually oh sorry
no no they're truly it's like a cult of
disney they have stuffed animals of
ariel the mermaid and stuff like what
the heck i would say it's not exactly
that it's almost this mutually parasitic
relationship the left sees disney as a
vehicle for promoting their ideas and
disney believes that they can extract
some profit from left-wing audience
members if they promote those ideals and
as soon as either doesn't need the other
or they rise to power and get what they
want they're going to throw each other
under the bus yeah it's tough to tell
what these specific people what their
intentions were i don't know if they
were trying to support evil no they were
saying it was racist
right
what a shock
so i guess i guess this this protest
wasn't actually about disney though so
i think this one there was a protest i'm
pretty sure there's a protest about the
disney thing apparently this one was it
was from the uh uh the black caucus or
something in florida i think this is not
actually just give me fake news if
you're going to be fake news you have to
go
today disney was protested i i can send
you the video on let me see if i can
pull up tonight they were chanting fight
back fight back
at the yeah but i think that might have
been something different maybe no let me
grab it disney
oh they're way too powerful i don't know
if power is the right word because money
isn't going to get what i what i saw on
twitter earlier was people saying that
they were protesting the disney thing
like the disney vote was happening but
the orlando sentinel says they were
protesting something that would remove
black democratic lawmakers or something
like that so you guys think we should
break up disney the monopoly is it a
monopoly yet it owns marvel at bought
maker studios after i was building that
thing well so so right
floridapolitics.com says house passes
bill ending disney plus carve out gavels
uh gavels out amid protests okay what i
just sent you sorry i can't pull it up
on this computer can you tell me how to
find it on twitter yeah what's the tweet
i'll retweet it
listen to that
dead space
hot air sorry i'm so bad with
interrupting who owns disney that's what
i'm looking at right now what's your
that's you lauren underscore southern
this was all a an elaborate plot to get
people to follow my twitter
underscore
i can't believe you're still on twitter
and still put on these two bills
it is my hope that we will be able to
proceed civilly and with decorum and
with respect for one another
read the next bill
it's like the 1800s under bradley senate
bill 4c built to be entitled and
actually to independent special
districts no i think they're protesting
something about independent special
that
districts
but the people are yelling something
about black people standing up and
fighting back i think what happened so
it spilled into the second one look at
the headline here house passes bill
ending disney plus carve out gavels out
amid protests you see what they do they
make the story about that and then they
say it's a mid-protest so you assume the
protests are actually about disney keep
playing that video though let's see if
they are still yelling about
oh i can't hear it yeah i think the
sound was cut
[Applause]
[Applause]
i mean look she's making good fine you
recognize to explain your bill
thank you mr speaker i can't hear what
they're saying they're saying something
when when black lawmakers under attack
what do we do stand up fight back i
wonder if there's a quote in here
because yeah
okay well you maybe you caught me on
some fake news here that's good like
dude if you're gonna do fake news you
have to do in the newscaster voice
lauren no no no no i don't that's the
mistake i made i don't blame you for it
because this is exactly what i saw as
well they're like everyone's all of
these people were tweeting
they passed the bill cutting out
disney's taxes amid protests and you
can't really hear what the protests are
saying and when you look at news
articles that frame it this way can we
pull this one up again when they
literally say they they passed the bill
ending the carve out amid protests
they're manipulating you into thinking
the protests were about that i am not
fake news i am a victim of fake news
yeah really i've gone through that a lot
writing articles with minds in the early
days like at what point do you have to
pass do you pass the book or take
responsibility when you read a fake
article and then you present it to the
masses yeah
yeah so they said the protests began as
democrats debate time expired on the
bill to pass congressional maps drafted
by desantis's office democrats called
desantis involvement a breach of the
separation of powers and argued the maps
would reduce the representation of black
floridians in congress in a statement
after the house adjourned sprouls issued
a statement accusing some members of
violating house rules and hijacking the
process so yeah what they were
protesting was that the the map
congressional map is going to cut out
two black lawmakers okay so we got we
got taken for a ride by these headlines
but uh we we caught it we caught it i
didn't i didn't believe a word of it at
all that you guys no i mean like we
corrected this stuff well that's good
why this is conversational when you just
have newscaster voice reading it you
don't get the back and forth the
real-time correction well see i actually
typically what happens with us is i
didn't pull up that story because i
couldn't hear what they were yelling so
when you brought up i was like oh yeah
you know like i heard that too it's a
good thing we pulled it up though
because now these headlines i mean come
on man look at this headline
that headline is going to be on twitter
someone's going to see it and that's
exactly what happened with what i what i
that's exactly what happened to me i saw
that and i was like oh yeah i heard that
those people were were protesting tax
cuts and then you pulled up and you're
like ah they got me yeah just reading
past the headline is a superpower where
where is snopes when you need them you
know
fact check false they could have put
like a mid war because they're talking
about the war in ukraine we didn't mean
anything about
what right that's that's something that
you got to be really careful of too
because um
depending on what the headlines you use
for stories are
so
it's tough because i'll i'll do youtube
videos that way when i'm trying to make
a point about two things happening
simultaneously or having some
relationship
but you see how the media will do it
they'll say something like you know
ian ian crossland throws out throws
major fit as sheamus steals lucky charms
which is true you think sheamus stole
them and that's why he's angry and then
you read it it's like sheamus was 20
miles away when it happened eating the
lucky charms on video oh the best one it
was
no what was it news newsweek no i'm not
gonna say i can't remember who it was
but they published that uh
a woman who criticized putin had died
she had disappeared been kidnapped and
died and then when you read the article
her boyfriend had murdered her but the
headline and the photo was a picture of
putin and this woman that's it
shout out to media matters
that article they they published an
article saying you know podcast host
says something about gay marriage
yeah they said uh it was like tim cast
irl host
uh attacks marriage equality
and uh
says it leads to grooming and it was
part of a conversation that we had where
i stated my position which is that there
is no such thing as gay marriage
marriage is between a man and a woman uh
but the person who tweeted it out was
basically trying to make it sound like
tim had changed his position on gay
marriage right let me show this so media
matters wrote tim cast irl panelists
attack marriage equality suggested has
led to normalizing grooming they show
you know here's the thumbnail for the
video it's me and then they actually say
i think they said in the tweet you got
to watch out for these grifters changing
their positions and in it it's like i
can't remember if it was the media
matters tweet or it was it was the first
iteration of what i saw i need to double
check i wasn't on that show that night
either that's really annoying so it's
like me saying
the issue for me is it's not gay
marriage or slippery slope fallacy i
think two consenting adults is not the
issue obviously there's a lot of
traditional conservatives have an issue
with that i disagree the issue is with
children who can't consent that's always
been the point it's like
i'm i literally we had a discussion with
jason whitlock and i'm like i'm okay
with gay marriage i think it's a good
thing but like i don't like the slippery
slope fallacy in this context because
i'm like dude if something is bad it's
bad then you don't say
because of this might make something bad
no no say no to bad things you say okay
to good things or to things that are
aligned with your values you debate them
too that's what the show's all about
well it's funny because after i made my
point which was absolutely correct and
absolutely accurate you said you
disagreed with me so they just as easily
could have made the headline tim poole
supports our you know lame left-wing
position on this
uh
well i shouldn't be but i am surprised
that this is like a headline it kind of
shows how not represented the average
person is in media because like what
percentage of the planet are christians
muslim you know
that all of those people don't believe
in gay marriage
the majority anyways so like is it
should it be that surprising that a host
on a tv show
would have a disagreement on this issue
is that really worthy of a media matters
article or are you guys just admitting
that there is like no representation of
how many people on the planet tim 2.38
billion are christians are christians
wow yeah now do [ __ ]
well lauren i don't know if you know
this but the only reason that you could
ever oppose the left-wing orthodoxy on
uh matters of human sexuality is if you
actually just like specifically hate
people for being gay that's it two
billion yeah yep so if you if so so if
you take
islam and christianity together we're
talking about four point three eight
billion people did you just pull up the
majority
majority of the earth of the earth you
can't have them represented that is a
shocking opinion no no
look media matters i think it i think
they're allowed to have their opinions
on whatever they want the problem is
that the headline of that article is
just stupid
but it's just a panelist it says panel
lists and i think it was okay no so it
was alec brusowitz and sheamus
alex agreed with you if i'm not mistaken
he said that he believed in this this
fictional i'm okay with gay marriage
bruce said i'm okay with gay marriage
personally okay whatever but the stuff
that's come after it it's been messed up
so i was the person who said the true
things and you guys got attacked
truth
is is that the truth ian i'm not sure we
had jason whitlock on he said he
disagree with gay marriage we talked
about it i said i i thought it was a
good thing there are many people that
were formerly democrats that when this
issue was settled they were like i can
vote republican now because that was a
big deal for me
now i think if you want to talk slippery
slope the issue is if it's bad it's bad
and you you call it bad i don't think
this i don't think it's a slippery slope
to be like consenting adults can do what
they want children can't consent they
never will be able to and you're not
going to change that no matter what yeah
so i and this is the thing i um would
agree that it's a bad art it's a bad
argument to say this thing which is like
otherwise good could lead to this bad
thing so we shouldn't do it i mean my
argument is that marriage is between a
man and a woman and because enshrining
these
unions which are
not representative that in a road the
family incorporating those into our
definition of marriage legally is a bad
thing to do it will lead to other bad
things and i oh you're gonna say oh i
can't believe how left wing your take is
marriage is obviously between a
christian man and a christian woman oh
yeah you're talking about christian
marriage so there's there's legal
marriage which is a uh just a legal
union you go to the courthouse you sign
some papers and then you have the joint
bank account you don't get taxed when
you give your wife six hundred grand but
then the marriage exists there's
christian religious christianity it's
like a spiritual blend yeah yeah well
there's sacramental marriages yeah yeah
yeah and you gotta define what you're
talking about when you when you're
comfortable with who can do it because
like legally they everyone has the right
to get married i mean i think for the
most part every adult in this country
right at the moment has the there are
there are some states where so this is
actually funny i think my brother was
looking into this what states in the in
the country allow cousin marriage what
states allow gay marriage and what
states allow gay cousin marriage
and i think new york might be the only
one i don't know let me let me if i can
find it
wait
that allows all three is that what
you're saying
well it's just two have we really
reached equality if people can't marry
their dogs
um no no okay first yes maybe maybe
wait hold on in arizona first cousin
marriage only if both parties are 65 or
older wait one is interesting
what because they're not gonna have kids
they're afraid of inbreeding yeah yeah
yeah oh interesting arizona
eugenics that's super cool so i think
not eugenics but that yeah yeah yeah
look look
new york
and california allow you to gay marry
your cousin
wicket why do they make fun of alabama
like your first cousin oh wait hold on
so uh so
what's
let me see if i can pull this up yeah
where's uh so in the in the south you
can gay mary actually no no no hold on
hold on let me see
by state uh let's see well wait a minute
well i suppose because the the federal
government court has ruled so all that
you got to do is look you can see south
carolina georgia um
what do we have is that is that alabama
which state is that one that's
mississippi right yeah yeah
mississippi's on the left i don't know
these puzzle pieces puzzle pieces and
florida that's right canadian they do
allow oh yeah alaska hawaii
surprisingly you can gay mary your
cousin in a large portion of this
country wow but it's most blast
you know there's interesting questions
there about
the challenge of the libertarian
argument
so we were talking about the moral
foundations the other day and one of the
moral foundations is like
would you allow two consenting adults
in any circumstance their like their own
private you know life and the argument
for gay marriage was always like two
consenting adults in the privacy of
their own home can do whatever they want
it's like
what if it's like a daughter and a
father
yeah i'd no because inbreeding it's
dangerous at least from what we know
about scientifically
well i don't i don't think that liberty
is even for the child the danger is for
the uh
the kid that would be in the
relationship with their father
like forget the whole eugenics if she
was 18 i guess if she's a concepting
adult yeah
but i think there's like i'm not i don't
know the science on inbreeding but i
know that historically it can get pretty
bad i had a mouse that inbred with its
child and had another mouse that had a
breathing problem that is and i rest my
case
[Laughter]
source i don't know joshua
you had you had a mice that you had as
pets that were basically they just kept
breathing and breathing and they're
breeding with their kids my source the
british
although i think humans came from in
breeding in breeding each other eating a
bunch of mushrooms and then breeding so
maybe just the weak and breads die off
and then the healthy ones create a new
species
so why do you believe that i'm kidding a
thought
you can marry your dad what and what
rhode island you can gay marry your dad
or your son
uh oh wait wait wait hold on
okay no i guess you can't get married
it's weird some states rhode island has
repealed its criminal incest statute
it seems kind of weird to me it's very
complex
but there are real challenges to the
libertarian argument because
as ian was mentioning there's there's
there's risks like there's a reason why
you don't do it
you have deformities and and serious
problems and so that's why there's laws
against it but i genuinely think as we
move towards this anyone can be anything
and do whatever they want phase of
reality or like people are trying to
create you're going to see a lot more of
this i i'm willing to bet that we're you
know 10 or 20 years out from
contending adults can do whatever they
want in any capacity i swear to the
pendulum swings that's how that's like a
weird part of reality like the kings of
the old they would marry their daughter
to their cousin to keep the bloodline
what they would call i don't think
they'd call it pure but it was to keep
like all the money in the family and all
the power in the family basically
i believe the the ancient egyptians
would do that with their royalty as well
i'm curious how common that was among
royal families
apparently was really sickly as a result
oh yes siblings is also yeah yeah uncle
in this is is illegal they say
individual statutes very widely rhode
island has repealed its criminal incest
statute and only criminalizes incestuous
marriage
ohio targets only parental figures so
that means a brother and sister
i think would be allowed two brothers
could gay marry
that's okay that's really interesting so
you've got the laws around like okay you
don't want to have incest because
obviously that's going to cause problems
with the kids but then you look at
people who have like serious diseases
genetic diseases that they can pass down
to their kids like do they outlaw them
breeding no that's what the nazis did so
they're not like if yeah that there's
the problem so if you're gonna ban these
people from it because of birth defects
and problems then why not ban people
with disease diseases that they'll pass
down and that's the argument the left
will come out when they say you're a
fascist for not allowing brothers to
love each other i don't think more of
wrong makes it the other wrong better
you just don't you want less wrong stuff
also i'm not this is not um an argument
from like moral foundations or anything
but one objection that comes up
in my mind immediately is that you know
who is related to to whom you know who
the siblings are you you don't go around
doing genetic tests of everyone to know
if a person has a disease no in iceland
they do
interesting they have an app where they
have to you have have you heard this in
iceland they have an app to check to
make sure you're not cousins hmm
oh because it's like an isolated
population yeah i saw a reddit post the
other day where someone was like very
visually disabled like you know arm
issues face issues like so you could see
it like right away and she
put a little tick tock up that was like
oh people told me i shouldn't have kids
but i did and she's holding her baby and
the baby is clearly very deformed too
and all of the people on reddit were
like you shouldn't have you shouldn't
have you shouldn't have which was very
interesting so like
yeah this conversation's been happening
in the beginning brings up a really
really great point but that will bring
us to
strange a strange position if
what is the argument uh for for the laws
banning
parental or lineal or direct family
relationships and it is typically
because of
the likelihood of the increase or the
creation of deformities but then you you
argue to people who already have those
deformities have a right to have kids
and they do
yeah so well i think i think i don't
there's but there's a good argument to
be made nature did not intend for people
to reproduce or procreate with their
siblings i don't think there's an
argument to be made that like nature
didn't intend people with disabilities
to procreate wait say that again i don't
i mean there's a good argument to be
made look nature did not intend people
who are directly related to procreate
i don't think that there's an argument
to be made like nature does not entice
people with disabilities
because most people with disabilities
today wouldn't even survive in a natural
state without our extreme scientific
like inventions that keep them breathing
and going into hospitals every day so
like nature literally intended for them
to die so i would argue that a person
should not get married and start a
family unless they are in a position to
take care of that family for themselves
but if they are able to do that it
doesn't matter if they have a disability
or not it's their choice i think tribal
history was very incestuous when there
was only like 12 people they won they
would have to there's no other choice
and that's kind of where it all began
we've really gone down the rabbit hole
so speaking of look what disney's done
to us yes
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you